[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 132 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very, very well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
So this week, Mark, we are
going to be talking with Thadeu
from Hand Talk, out of Brazil.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
talk about the fact
that they've built a product
that translates written
and spoken Portuguese into
Brazilian Sign Language, which
is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
definitely very much enjoyed
that interview.
But as always, before we
get into the interview
we will talk about the
cool things of the week
as well as, at the
end of the interview,
we will talk about our
question of the week.
And one question
we have, which is
coming from one
of our colleagues,
is what does a Go developer
need to know about GCP?
MARK MANDEL: What do
they need to know?
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
What do they need to know?
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't know.
Is it something special?
We will find out, so stay tuned.
But before we get
into all of that,
as always, cool
things of the week.
And one of the cool
things of the week--
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARRICK: --we
were advertising for Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we were.
MELANIE WARRICK: We were.
We were videotaped in mid
ending of a podcast, sort of,
and yeah, we've got
a funny little video
that's out there that
you can check out.
MARK MANDEL: Three questions
with a Googler, if you
wanted to know things about us.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, if you want
to know what are some of are
favorite items on our desks,
you should check out that video.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
Yeah, it's a good video.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
we'll include that link
in our show notes, as always.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So we also announced
a new region.
So GCP arrives in the Nordics
for the new region in Finland.
[WIND BLOWING AND BELLS RINGING]
We've doing a really good
job of opening up new regions
all the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, and
the regions I was lead
to improvements in our latency.
But yeah, that's
europe-north1, and it's
joining the Netherlands,
Belgium, London,
and Frankfurt in Europe.
We also announced that Google
AI is going to be in Ghana.
And so in the fall,
they're opening up
a research center specifically
located in Accra, Ghana,
I think is the name.
So yeah, it's just
pretty exciting.
And I know there's been a
lot of work in that region
to train and do training
on AI and digital training
for machine learning and
other technical skills.
So this will be wonderful
to have that research
center set up in that region.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We want to also
highlight we seem
to be doing a lot of stuff
with teammates recently
fellow developer
advocate Yufeng Guo
has a blog post about
BigQuery data sets.
As he says it specifically,
the big data is great,
but getting your hands on large
data sets is no easy feat.
So he has a list of BigQuery
data sets that you might
be interested in playing with.
MELANIE WARRICK: And he
shows you how to access them.
And I think it's
about 40 data sets,
so you don't have
to actually pay
for the storage of those sets.
You can get access
to them and do
machine learning and other
types of projects with those.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there's
lots of cool stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Lots of stuff.
Last week was DockerCon, and
we had a number of Googlers
who were there and speaking
on different topics.
One of our fellow
teammates, Michelle Casbon,
who we had on the
podcast a few weeks back,
talking about data science.
So she did a demo at DockerCon.
David A-ron-chack?
MARK MANDEL: Aronchick, yeah.
Aronchick.
Close enough.
MELANIE WARRICK: Aronchick?
OK.
So anyway, they did a demo.
They were showing Docker with
GCP and they're showing TPUs.
And one thing I
wanted to highlight
that she gave a
shout-out to on Twitter
was that because DockerCon
supports child care
at conferences that enabled
her to actually be there.
And so other
conferences out there
who are trying to figure out
how to increase their diversity,
consider adding child care.
MARK MANDEL: That's super
nice-- super, super nice.
Last but not least, I just want
to highlight that Unite Berlin
is on right now.
Probably just before
we did this podcast,
the keynote would have happened.
You might want to
check that out.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
think you should.
MARK MANDEL: You
should have a look.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
it's time for us to go and speak
with Thadeus about Hand Talk.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: This week we
have with us Thadeu Luz, who
is from Hand Talk,
who's here to talk to us
about what Hand Talk does
and how it's using GCP.
Thadeu, thanks for joining us.
THADEU LUZ: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thadeu, can you tell us
a little bit about the company?
What does Hand Talk do?
THADEU LUZ: So I'm a founder
and CPO at Hand Talk,
which is a startup based here
in the city of Maceió in Brazil,
which is on the coast and very
warm weather and nice beaches.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
THADEU LUZ: And I'm
also a Google developer
expert in Firebase.
Hand Talk is a company that
offers automatic sign language
interpretation solutions for
users and companies as well.
And we do that through a
friendly virtual 3D character
named Hugo.
MELANIE WARRICK: So how did you
guys come up with this company?
THADEU LUZ: OK, so Hand Talk
started when, in 2011, I
came back from Canada.
I was living in Toronto
for two years with my wife
and working on the VFX industry.
That's actually my background,
in computer graphics
and digital compositing.
And when I came back, a couple
of friends invited me to help
with this project they
were working on, which was
a prototype for a demo day
they were going to have here
in Maceió.
And the idea was to
come up with an app that
would translate to sign language
using a virtual character.
And they needed someone
that had experience
with character design and 3D
animation to finish him off,
so that's how I started.
MELANIE WARRICK:
How did the company
decide to work on
from translating
spoken and written Portuguese
into Brazilian Sign Language?
THADEU LUZ: This idea was
a school project, actually,
from my co-founder and
my partner, Ronaldo.
He's a CEO now.
He had this idea for
a very long time.
He came up with this product
when he was in university,
and he needed to do that
to come up with a marketing
campaign for the
product, so he thought
of doing something at
the time which was using
desktop computers or notebooks.
And this was a long time ago,
in 2004, even before the iPhone.
So after that, we
thought that this
could work for mobile devices.
And we did this demo
for this contest here,
this local contest in Maceió,
and we won the first prize.
Everybody loved Hugo.
And we used the money
as seed investment
to open up the company.
And that's what we've been
working on ever since.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Can you tell us more
about the problem too?
Is the translation from,
say, Portuguese or even just
any sort of written
language to sign language,
is that kind of one-to-one?
Or how complicated is that?
THADEU LUZ: OK, so
that's a good question,
because it's not
at all one-to-one.
Sign languages are languages by
themselves, proper languages.
They're not signed English
or signed Portuguese.
They have a structure and
a grammar and morphology
that's specific to them.
So when we first started, we
thought that the hardest part
would be to animate a
language, because there
are quite a few signs.
In Brazilian Sign
Language, I think
it's estimated it's over 40,000.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
THADEU LUZ: And we
thought it would
be really hard to
animate a language,
but the actual hard part is
to restructure the grammar
and make it work as
a different language.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds like
this is very similar to, say,
a translation between French
and English or English
and Portuguese as much as
it is like a spoken language
to a sign language.
THADEU LUZ: Exactly.
One other important
thing to note
is that there are over
200 different sign
languages in the world today.
Brazilian Sign Language, or
Libras, what I'll call it
is the Brazilian
official sign language.
But in the US, you guys use
ASL, and it's important, also,
to say that there
is no relationship
between the oral language of a
country and the sign language
that they use.
ASL is used in Canada,
and Mexico as well,
in some parts of Central
America, Asia, in Africa--
ASL is actually the most popular
sign language in the world.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
In terms of the app itself,
how can you access it?
How is it used?
THADEU LUZ: The
app is free to use.
You can find it on Google
Play and Apple's App Store.
And you can download
it, and if you're
interested in learning
sign language for now,
you can just type or
say whatever you want,
and Hugo will sign
it back to you.
We also have a
couple of sessions
where you can get started
with sign language,
learning groups of signs
like fruits and colors
if you're new to
Brazilian Sign Language.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, in terms of
the app, why Hugo?
Why was the avatar designed the
way it was and Hugo the name?
THADEU LUZ: When I
was designing him,
I wasn't really sure
how he would look like.
But I was pretty clear of what
I wanted him to represent.
So we were making
this character that
would be not the mascot
but the product itself.
I wanted him to have the
mission of the company.
And I wanted him to look
friendly and also credible,
because that's what we were
aiming for as a company.
And also, I wanted him to be
specific for sign language
communication.
So I gave him a few
characteristics like long
limbs, and large hands, and
also a large face for facial
expressions , because
this is really,
really important for
communication in sign language.
And as for the name, it
was my wife that named him.
I had picked this placeholder
name just at random
so that I could name the files
in the geometry and things
like that.
And she came up
one day and said,
he doesn't look like that.
He looks like a Hugo.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
THADEU LUZ: And
when she said it,
it was pretty obvious
that she was right.
Everybody agreed, and
the name really stuck.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I love the details
that you have to think about.
I mean, that's
impressive to think
about it in terms of the design
of the character itself--
the long limbs, the large
hands, the facial expressions.
These are things people
wouldn't normally consider
but you have to consider
when you're doing design.
THADEU LUZ: Yeah,
and even the clothes
that he's wearing went
through quite a few iterations
to get to something
that wasn't very formal
but at the same time
wasn't too casual.
And he has a tie,
but not a suit.
I think we got it right.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
I'd love to get stuck in
more into how the translation
process is made.
You kind of hit it like
you just dropped it in,
and I was like,
wow, that's amazing,
in that the translation is
not just the hand expressions,
but also the facial
expressions as well.
So I'd love to hear more
about how that works.
THADEU LUZ: Yes.
Facial expressions are really
important in sign language.
They're basically the
difference between a question--
I'm not sure about ASL, I'm
talking about Brazilian Sign
Language, which I know for
sure-- that the difference
between a question
and an affirmation.
So if you do the
same sign, and you
don't do the facial
expression, you
can't be really sure if the
person is saying or asking.
MARK MANDEL: So
it's like a tone.
THADEU LUZ: Yes, and also
the facial expressions
are built on the signs.
Some signs require facial
expressions for them to work.
Some signs are only
facial expressions.
It's hard to explain here
because people are not
going to have the
visual, but there
are some signs that are
just a facial expression.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What's one that you
would say that is a facial
expression that's a sign?
THADEU LUZ: "Thief."
The sign for "thief" in
Brazilian Sign Language
is like this.
MARK MANDEL: He's
sticking his tongue
into the side of his mouth.
THADEU LUZ: Yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
If you do this, it's
like a discreet way
to say, look, there's a thief.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
Yeah, tell us more about how
technologically this works.
I really want to hear about how
these translations are made.
THADEU LUZ: OK, the translation
happens in two steps,
and they're quite distinct.
One of them is to
translate the oral language
into what we call gloss.
Glossing is a process of writing
a language in another language.
And that's required
for sign language
because, unfortunately,
there's no official way
to write in sign language.
There are a couple of
attempts to make that,
to create symbols to represent
the position and hand
shape of signs, but there's
nothing official yet.
And that's one of
the reasons why
it's hard to find
data on sign language,
because it's really hard
to represent like we
do with our language letters.
The first step is to
convert oral language,
like Portuguese, to gloss,
which is written sign language.
And then we can
convert the gloss
into signs or fingerspelling.
We have a database
of signs, and we
can swap each signed
tag to an animation
and hand it back to the user.
And whenever we
don't have a sign,
we do what's actually
done in real life, which
is to fingerspell the word.
If deaf people come by a word
they have never seen before,
like "Google," for instance,
they can fingerspell it.
They'll fingerspell G-O-O-G-L-E,
and once they get acquainted
to it, they come up
with a sign for it.
So that's exactly what our
transition system does.
If we find a new word or a
proper noun, like a name,
we can fingerspell it.
And if we know that they're
referring to that one
specific person,
like Barack Obama,
we can swap that for the sign
instead of finger spelling.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
what's the sign for "Google?"
THADEU LUZ: I'm not quite sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: No worries.
[LAUGHTER]
THADEU LUZ: Let me
ask Google real quick.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're not sure either,
but I'm sure we will look
it up and find out later.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so was there
more that you wanted
to explain in terms of
the way you translate?
Because I'm very
curious, especially now
with where things are
at with neural nets,
like how you're building
out the translation
from being able to read to have
spoken and written language
translated into
actual animation.
THADEU LUZ: Yeah.
OK, so the animation process
is really straightforward--
just swap the ID by the
animation or fingerspell it.
But the hard part is really
to get the grammar right
for sign language,
because currently we
are using a statistical
machine translation
system that is phrase-based.
That's what we have
currently in production.
But what we really would like
is to have a neural machine
translation system implemented,
especially because we
have the opportunity now
with some tools that Google
has released in the
past couple of months
to have this translation
system deployed to the device,
to the end user.
This last TensorFlow
Summit, they
released TensorFlow.js,
which is a way
to direct inference on
the web browser, which
is amazing in training as well.
And Firebase, which is
our primary backend,
also released a
machine learning kit,
which is also super promising.
There's many things that we
would love to do with it.
And when we nail that neural
machine translation system
and if it's light enough,
we can allow the user
to do translations
offline, which
is something that is one of
our top requests for features.
MELANIE WARRICK:
When we first met,
we were talking about
how your group went
through the Launchpad
studio program.
You were one of the
initial companies that
went through this, and this,
of course, is Launchpad Studio.
We had a podcast on that at
the beginning of the year.
What kind of
products and services
did it give you access
to that you've been
able to use in your company?
THADEU LUZ: We were on the first
class of the Launchpad Studio,
and our boot camp
was on January 2016.
And it was amazing--
really, really good.
I remember that there
were two things that
became really clear after that,
and those are two meetings
that we keep going back to.
And one of the
things was when we
did a UX test with someone that
had never used the app before.
It sounds really
basic, but we were
able to see where
people were really
struggling to find
information that we
thought was really obvious.
And it's really
enlightening when
you're able to see
someone that has never
used your app before trying
to find the things that you
already know where they are,
and you're not allowed to talk.
So one of the
things that followed
after that was a
redesign of the app
so that things would be
even clearer to you find
and that people that
were arriving there
for the first time wouldn't
have to look for them as much.
And the other thing that
was really important for us
in the Launchpad was
that we've been asked
what was the product about?
Who was it trying
to help exactly?
Is it the person that
uses their oral language
as a first language?
Or is it the deaf user?
And the idea was that, if our
app doesn't do translation
from sign language
to oral language,
how is the deaf user
going to use it?
And are we trying to build a
translator or an education app?
Because those are two
very different things.
If you're trying to
build a translator,
you can just go ahead and
listen to the mic right away.
And if you're building
an education app, what
you want to do is to assess how
much sign language that person
knows and to help him
or her get started
with the first basic signs
that they're going to learn.
| we opted for it
being an education app,
because we believe that that's
what's most important for us
to do.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What are the biggest
challenges with sign language?
THADEU LUZ: Sign language
is really peculiar.
Not many people know
this, but sign language
is really, really different
from other kinds of conditions
like blindness or
mobility impairment,
because sign language
creates a culture.
And that's the main difference,
because deaf people experience
life in a very different
manner than people that
can hear the life experience
that they have is primarily
visual so everything comes
down to what is seen,
and that's why sign
language is really
like a natural
language for them.
That's why sign
language feels more
natural than any other
language for them.
The second reason is
there's one concept, which
is the concept of
deaf culture, which is
really important to understand.
When you say that someone is
deaf, with an uppercase D,
it means that they
are culturally deaf.
It's not only they
are clinically deaf,
they can't hear,
or maybe they can
hear with the aid of cochlear
implants or hearing aids.
But what that means is that
they identify with deaf culture.
They likely have deaf
friends, and they
enjoy what's called
deaf arts, and they
are aware of deaf history.
And there are lots of cultural
manifestations to that.
And one other thing that
deafness is really peculiar
is the fact that sometimes
deaf children struggle
to learn their first
language, and this
is a real, real big
problem because 90% to 95%
of deaf children are born
from hearing parents.
And that makes it really
likely that their child
is the very first deaf
person that they ever met.
And it is hard to learn sign
language for someone that
came here-- it's really hard.
So it is important
for deaf parents
to have help when they're
trying to learn sign language
and make tools
available for them
so they can acquire
sign language
or learn sign language
as much as they
can to have a
better communication
with their children.
There are a couple of
interesting stories
we have about this.
One of the things that
really makes our day
is when we get
feedback from users,
and they send us emails
and Facebook messages
saying that our app is
helping them have a better
relationship with
their daughter,
for instance, because they have
a daughter that's 10 years old
and she's deaf.
She goes to deaf school,
and in school she
can communicate perfectly and
has no problem whatsoever.
But when she gets home,
she has no one to talk to.
And to hear that
her parents, that
are using our app to learn sign
language in their spare time
to be able to better
communicate with their daughter,
is something that
we really value.
That's why, way
back then when we
were deciding on which
business model to pursue,
we decided that we would not
want to charge for the app
whatsoever.
It's not our intention to charge
$5, $6, $10 to a parent that
wants to learn sign language
so that they can communicate
with their kid or
a friend that wants
to learn the basic signs
so that they can say hello
to a coworker and
things like that.
So that's why we had the idea of
offering services to companies
so that companies
can pay if they
want to make one
of their channels
available also in sign language.
MARK MANDEL: This is amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And I love
the story about it.
Just your ethos around the
entire company is phenomenal.
I really would love to also
just get stuck a bit more
into the technical
side of things.
I know you're very
large Firebase users.
Why did you choose Firebase?
What gets you excited
about using that product?
THADEU LUZ: Our
first server version
was done entirely
by me on Node.js,
and I coded the whole
thing from scratch.
And even though it's not that
hard to make a server use
your system with log, in
log out, reset password,
and create account forms,
and things like that--
it's not that hard--
I find it really important
to be able to have
that information
really secure, to store
the passwords the right way.
And that's not
that trivial, it's
really important
to have security
and to have your app be stable.
And that's one of the most
amazing things of all Firebase,
that keeps us coming
back to Firebase,
is the fact that we can create
user accounts and log in--
there are third-party
authentication systems--
really easily and reliably.
And also, one of the things
that we didn't really think that
would benefit as much, which
is a real-time database,
the fact that you can receive
updates from the database
directly.
But it's really amazing.
It really changes the
perception of the user when,
for instance, they know that
someone is on their website,
and they can see the
dashboard update instantly
without having to
refresh the page.
That's something that's
really, really helpful as well.
There are other
things in Firebase
that gets me really
excited about it.
One of them is the fact
that, in 2016, they
released the Google
Cloud Functions, which
is an amazing tool.
Not having to manage
servers is something
that's really valuable to
us, because sometimes we
do have huge spikes in
usage, like when a big news
outlet makes a
blog post about us,
and we have a huge
spike in translations
and relying on cloud
functions for that.
And not having to
monitor instances
is really helpful as well.
So there are many things in
Firebase that I really like,
but those three are the
most important, I believe.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
THADEU LUZ: There are also other
Google Cloud Platform services
that we are using that
are really helpful too.
OK, one of the hard things
about making a translation
system for sign language is that
data is really hard to come by.
I know that ASL is not as
hard as it is for Libras,
but to find data on Libras
is really, really hard.
It would be awesome
if we could do it
just like Google
Translator does,
which is use something like
the European Parliament corpora
or a database of
translator websites,
where you have references
for sometimes two,
sometimes three, four
different languages.
And you use that to feed
your translation system.
But with sign language,
we don't really have that.
We have to create our
own corpus from scratch.
Our Bitext is done on
a tool that we created,
which actually is heavily
inspired by Google Translate
community, which is
the web app that you
can contribute to translations.
And we have a system
kind of like that
but for sign language,
where you can also
pick the signs you want or
determine if a certain tag is
fingerspelled.
And that's how we produce
the data for our translation
system.
MELANIE WARRICK: How much
data do you have for training?
THADEU LUZ: Yeah, our corpus
is around half a million
sentences.
MARK MANDEL: And you're using
Google Cloud for managing that?
How does that all work?
THADEU LUZ: OK, so
we use data flow
to clean up and
merge two databases
that we have with
information on our Bitext
with Portuguese and
Brazilian Sign Language.
And we train everything
on Cloud ML, which is also
a huge, huge deal for us.
Cloud ML is a godsend.
MELANIE WARRICK: How so?
THADEU LUZ: As I mentioned, we
have some quite long sentences,
and we have a bunch of
unknown words, like the name.
Many people translate
their names in the app.
They want to say, my
name is so and so.
And we have many unknown words
of names of entities and proper
nouns, and our system can
get really memory-intensive--
it consumes a lot of memory.
And it would be really hard
to train that on our hardware.
I have a MacBook, so it
would be really hard to train
that on hardware on premise.
So we've been using Cloud
ML since the beginning
to iterate and test new
versions of our neural machine
translation system, and it's
working really, really well.
It's amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
this is wonderful.
So one question I
have for you is,
I know we were saying how
it's focused on Portuguese
and Brazilian Sign Language.
What are your future
plans in terms
of sign language translation?
THADEU LUZ: We have
many features that we
would like to do on our app.
Some of them on the short term,
like American Sign Language,
but some of them are going to
take a bit longer to develop
the technology for them.
American Sign Language
we would like to be
done by the end of the year.
But we're closing a round
of funding right now,
and it's taken a little bit
longer than we expected.
We have to run the numbers again
to have a final date for when
the ASL is going to be ready.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
American Sign Language
is one that you're
targeting, hopefully,
by the end of the
year, depending on how
things are going with funding.
And other languages other
features that you're
interested in pursuing?
THADEU LUZ: One of
the other features
that we really would
love to implement
is doing it the
other way around.
Currently we only do oral
language to sign language,
but we would love to do sign
language to oral language,
to be able to use the device
camera to convert images
to oral language.
That would be something
very big for us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed,
especially with a way machine
learning is evolving from
object identification
and other classification and
predictive tooling around image
analysis.
This is wonderful.
Thadeu, if people out there
are interested in contributing
to your company and contributing
to the product, what are ways
that they can get involved?
THADEU LUZ: OK, I
thought of three things
that might be interesting.
One is that you know ASL or you
represent an institution that
deals with ASL.
You can get in touch with us to
see how we can either come up
with a partnership to help
improve our ASL translation
system.
So you can get in touch with
me on Twitter @thadeuluz.
And also, if you're
a data scientist
and you are aware of language
labeled or unlabelled
data sets for ASL
that are open, you
can send a link
to me, because I'm
pretty sure there are quite
a few data sets that I'm not
aware of yet on ASL.
And I'm looking for
them, collecting
them to know exactly
which ones we
can use to speed up the
process of coming up with data.
And if you're just curious about
sign language and would love
to hear from us when we release
the ASL version of our app,
you can go to handtalk.me/asl
and sign up to our newsletter
there.
And you're going
to be the first one
to know when we have the app
ready for English and American
Sign Language.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, this is great.
Thank you so much,
Thadeu, for joining us
and for sharing about
Hand Talk, about Hugo.
And you mentioned it's
available on Google Play.
So thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thanks so much.
THADEU LUZ: OK, thank you guys.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you, Thadeu, again,
for coming on the podcast.
I'm so glad we were able to talk
about what Hand Talk has built,
and what you're working
on, and where that's going.
I love these types
of tools because I
love how they are breaking down
more and more communication
barriers.
That's exciting to me in
terms of what technology
has the potential for.
All right, Mark, what
does a Go developer need
to know about GCP?
MARK MANDEL: What
doesn't a Go developer
need to know about GCP?
No, this is a great question.
We wanted to highlight
this because, yeah, we
had another teammate--
I think it's like
teammate-a-palooza.
I think we're just talking
about how amazing--
MELANIE WARRICK:
We love our team.
MARK MANDEL: --our
teammates are.
Eno Compton, Developer
Advocate for Go Google Cloud,
wrote a really amazing
article talking
about exactly these types
of things and basically
the choices that you have
in terms of where you
might want to host your code.
So maybe you might
want to put it on GCE,
Compute Engine, maybe you want
to put it on Kubernetes Engine,
maybe you want to put
you on App Engine.
He even sort of goes and has
a look at Cloud Functions,
talking about the unofficial
and unsupported native Go
runtime that exists.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's a nice
a review of GCP but from a Go
perspective.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really great.
So there's lots of options.
It goes through a lot
of the pros and cons.
He even talks about
machine learning APIs
and how you can use
that through Go as well.
It's worth a read.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
All right, Mark, are you going
to be speaking anywhere anytime
soon?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'm going to
be presenting at the Kubernetes
Community Meeting, which
I think is tomorrow, based
on the day this comes out,
in the morning, Pacific
time in the US.
There we go.
Let's get the time zones right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Time
zones are important.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put a link
to that in the show notes.
That's online, so anyone
can come in and listen.
I'm going to be
talking about Agones.
And then later this week,
I'm getting on a plane,
going to Denmark.
I'm going to go hang out
with their Unity friends.
They've called a hack week
that I'm going to go play with.
So expect lots of
tweets and social stuff
to come out of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Copenhagen's
fun, especially for food.
MARK MANDEL: Mmm.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
love the food there.
MARK MANDEL: What are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: I,
while you are away,
will be going to
speak at an event
that the Women in Machine
Learning and Data Science
and PyLadies our
joint organizing
called Paths to Data Science.
And so we'll include the
Meetup link in the show notes.
And that's on Tuesday, the 26th.
And then I'm speaking at
Stanford at the AI for All.
It's like a technology
camp for those who are
more in the high school space.
And so that is on June 28
that I will be speaking there.
MARK MANDEL: When you
say technology camp,
is that like in tents and stuff?
[HORN PLAYS]
MELANIE WARRICK:
Depends on who you
are in terms of whether
you consider that intense.
I don't know.
Technology, to me, seems
like fun and going to a camp.
MARK MANDEL: Is it a camp?
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
it's almost like band camp.
[HORN PLAYS]
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
it's technology camp.
MARK MANDEL: I've
done that before.
I've done, like, go out in
the bush with tents and dorms.
[DIDGERIDOO PLAYS]
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
It's not tents.
MARK MANDEL: No?
MELANIE WARRICK: No,
definitely not tents.
But it's all about learning--
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: --and
understanding and exposing
tech, especially to
people who are younger,
trying to get into the space.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another
podcast this week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]